41 take one marker Oh greetings everyone
Bill Nye here once again to answer your
science questions this is science
support part 3 James Ravel asks how come
we know more about space than we do
about our own ocean I heard that on the
dock somewhere well if you heard it on a
documentary James I guess you're set no
okay there's an old saying but it's
easier to explore the moon than the
bottom of the ocean that's true for
three reasons
the ocean is cold it's crushing and it's
corrosive that's why it's easier with
binoculars to explore the moon than it
is with a scuba mask from a department
store and just observe the bottom of the
ocean
carry-on James David Blanche flower BSc
he asks now that tardigrades have
settled on the moon I wonder what their
future holds will they successfully
rehydrate can they flourish in thousands
of years will they build spaceships and
return to Earth fascinating oh there's a
picture he's got a picture of a
tardigrade
tardigrades also called the water-bearer
you can see them with your naked eye you
said Nick oh my god
words settled I think crash landing in
the harsh vacuum of space on a planetary
body that has no atmosphere or liquid
water I think that's not the same as
settling I don't think they're gonna
settle the moon David carry on
Bill Nye assuming a perfect scenario
where the general disasters don't occur
if the earth stopped spinning would we
all feel dizzy
I guess so Matt attest you'll probably
be able to run Tony Phillips writes a
climate change question as it gets
hotter more air conditioning is used
heating up the air even more is there a
way to cool indoor spaces without
heating up the outdoors especially in
cities well Tony probably not because
what is the one thing you can count on
in this universe that's right Tony the
second law of thermodynamics heat just
spreads out man so when you pump the
heat out of this room or the balloon
you're sitting on putting outside the
outside gets a little bit warmer but the
scale of it
hope surprises you the amount of heat we
pump out of buildings ain't no nothing
compared to with the amount of heat that
we're holding in by adding greenhouse
gases to the Earth's atmosphere the heat
island effect of cities is as more from
hard scape paved surfaces buildings are
not soil for example and that's why
cities are so hot the AC thing is a
problem but it's just the hardscape that
gets us and that flippin second law of
thermodynamics I'm sorry
whoa man there's nothing we can do out
there we got a deal it's entropy entropy
killing us all hollow rights when will
teleportation happen I don't know
happens all the time in science fiction
but that's fiction
no it's just the information problem
alone probably makes heliport ation
impossible converting something like u
into a beam of electromagnetic signals
it's very very unlikely just taking you
apart and putting you back together
would take extraordinary amounts of
energy
ELISA asks honestly I have a science
degree and a partially completed
doctorate and I still have no idea what
a neutron does ok neutrons can make
things massive men and if you confuse
them together you can release a whole
bunch of energy which we hope is the
future
Liam asks if the mantle is filled with
lava why aren't the oceans boiling or at
least warmer than they are there's a
couple things first of all that the
oceans are not boiling and the earth
remains very warm inside is evidence of
an aphorism I hope you will embrace a
saying a way of looking at the world
that I hope you Liam will take to heart
if things were any other way things
would be different and here's what we
mean by that indeed the earth does
radiate a large amount but relatively
small amount of heat into the icy
blackness of space the bottom of the
ocean is the Earth's crust you got to go
down and
they're ten twenty thirty kilometres
most places to get to the mental carry
on Liam bill life aliens were to fly by
light-years away would they see the
dinosaurs of the Trojan War or something
since light they see is so old yes they
would spur key Bill Nye this is drew
asks Bill Nye why does the mean reflect
in one straight line when it hits the
ocean it may interest you to know that
it reflects in all different directions
when it hits the ocean just you as the
observer see a straight line and if you
don't believe me get your friends to
stand in the line along the beach where
you can call out to each other and ask
each other if you each see a straight
line and then ask yourself they're
parallel or if you don't trust your
friends and I don't blame you set up
cameras take pictures along a kilometer
or two carry on drew
Andrew Ralston says okay okay I'll say
how the planes work and I presume by
that Andrew you mean airplanes because
the Carpenters plane has a blade and you
push it along the carpenter pushes it
along and peels up the wood but an
airplane works like a bird you get the
momentum of air molecules going down
hasn't produces enough force to hold the
wing up and the way you get air
molecules going down is get the wing
going fast what about a helicopter
helicopter is wings that are spinning
and the propeller blades either the
exposed ones that you might see on what
we would call a propeller aircraft or
the turbine blades inside the tubes on a
jet airplane are they're going around in
a circle and they're pushing air
molecules back so fast that they push
the airplane forward it's not magic its
science
Gogi Rossum's asks I'm doing my best to
pronounce your name go gyro sons Bill
Nye if we took all the animals out of
the ocean how much shallower do you
think the ocean would get in other words
how much water do you
animals displace I'll bet it's less than
you think animals like you and I are
mostly water animals that live in the
ocean are almost all water I don't think
it would change that much since you
asked how much do you think my answer is
not much carry on go Jiro Suns drew
asked Bill Nye do you think aliens
actually exist
so you want me to resist making a joke
about my old boss I don't know if he was
an alien there are 200 billion stars in
our galaxy and there are at least that
many galaxies when I was in school it
was speculated that there what might be
a planet a single planet around one and
every hundred stars now with
observations from Hubble Space Telescope
Kepler space telescope other inferential
methods people think there probably
about ten planets around every star so
that's another factor of a thousand that
takes you into the to trillions in just
our galaxy if you got two trillion of
anything you got to figure something's
going to happen so there probably are
aliens through the cinturón and do
fabulous and important Twitter style
podcasts I don't know maybe carry on
aerobic and reek because he says the
asus or she says the H is silent are you
an alien bill sent here to educate the
human race and save us from our own
destruction yes I am an alien has been
I've been sent here like the landing
party that that one astronaut claims he
believes in no I'm not an M one of you
I'm one of us we're all in this together
links shall kill 89 Bill Nye how does
fusion work do you think we'll be able
to have fusion power plants where we use
nuclear power plants for 2050 fusion
works by overcoming what's called the
strong nuclear force
the strong nuclear interaction and I
believe it is quite reasonable we will
have fusion not by running a stream of
protons into deuterium or tritium oh no
but by running a stream of neutrons into
boron hydride gas stay tuned kc Kooning
writes bill nye I've been fascinated and
quite obsessed parenthetically with the
alternate parallel universe theory oh
you know that theory that theory about
the alternate parallel universe so my
question is this if such a thing where
exists with the laws of physics
necessarily have to apply to every
single universe well so here's the thin
KC let's let's just take history of
physics for example people got by they
built pyramids they built they
discovered round things roll made wheels
all kinds of agriculture was developed
without really formalizing the laws or
rules of physics or natural laws and so
people presume that they knew what we
call Newton's laws of motion were it for
centuries and it was great
we made all sorts of progress but then
relativity was discovered and then
quantum electrodynamics and we refined
the laws of physics people when you're
sophomoric view of the world the Isaac
Newton was wrong I think was pretty
flippin right but then was we made more
discoveries about the nature of mass and
white and quantum electrodynamics we
refined it so I presume if another
universe exists and it has what we might
call different laws of physics it
doesn't mean that our laws of physics
are necessarily wrong it just means
they're incomplete every day we learn a
little more Terry on kacie Brian Schmidt
asks didn't I hear we could get to the
next habitable planet in a few years
with this space sail just need to say
all the size of Texas in order to do it
say all the size of Texas is not going
to take us to another inhabitable
when in a few years but solar sails such
as light sail too may revolutionize
space exploration here in the solar
system because we can go to
extraordinary speeds with no rocket fuel
there are certain missions that solar
sails are ideal for put a solar sail
spacecraft at an inferior orbit closer
to the Sun than the earth is and keep an
eye out for asteroids or maybe more
importantly importantly coronal mass
ejections from the Sun which send a beam
of charged particles slashing through
space toward the earth which could
disable many many of our communication
systems so there are certain missions
that solar sails are ideal for but a
texas-sized one going to a nearby
habitable planet is probably not among
them and I remind you that it's not the
solar wind it's not particle streaming
from the Sun that give a solar sail
spacecraft to push it is light itself
photons there's about a hundred times
more pressure from photons than charged
particles fascinating I hope carry on
Brian bill nighy do insects feel gravity
the same way we do yes the spider-man
does whatever a spider can of course the
spiders aren't insects but he doesn't do
it because his understanding of gravity
is different he does it because because
he's not real thank you for your
questions we'll be back with more
science support number four coming soon
and when it does turn it up loud